[Music]
before we start do you have insurance
what your coverage good like you have
dental oh haha is there a hospital
nearby is it like too far about like 25
minutes I'd
say I just slapped you are you all right
what so you like to fight you ever win
no one ever wins a fight
[Music]
[Applause]
this ain't the holiday and pal all right
I'm
moving friend of mine suggested I come
talk to you I own a Road House out in
the Florida
Keys lately it's been attracting the
wrong
clientele I can pay you good money
judgeing by your car you need that well
I like my car think about it come on
one know who you are Elwood dton big
fan that guy's got a knife under his
shirt he just take a big step back and
pop me in the face you can do
it tell me about this bouncing act all
nice like he's Mr Rogers or something
but then he'll haul
off really interesting guy
overall Brant wants to take the
Roadhouse away from me he wants to build
some
Resort
I should warn you people have a certain
way of getting things done around
here hey fellas looks like you're having
a
smacking I got a tip for you don't let
no one get this close come
on let me guess you don't threaten me
tell me to get out of
town I get the impression that you can't
be
threatened
once KNX is on the job it's over
baby it takes a lot to get me angry but
when I
am I just can't let
go people seem a little aggressive
around
here is that one a friend of yours no I
just broke his
arm
[Music]